we are less than a week away from the
scheduled summit between President Trump
and North Korean Korean leader Kim
jong-un the US and the West want North
Korea to abandon its nuclear weapons
program North Korea might want the u.s.
to pull all or some of its troops out of
South Korea
tonight national security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin looks at that
relationship and what those changes
might mean defense secretary Jim mattis
on route back from a defense conference
in Singapore spent much of his time
reassuring allies that the US would not
be discussing the removal of US military
forces from Korea in exchange for North
Korea shuttering its nuclear program
it's not even a subject
the president tweeted today quote
meeting in Singapore with North Korea
will hopefully be the start of something
big we will soon see some South Koreans
suggest such a grand bargain should be
on the table Michael O'Hanlon of the
Brookings Institution suggests such a
discussion needs to occur but not at
this summit these conversations are
starting partly because President Trump
has said some things that make people
wonder if he might be willing to make
this kind of a grand bargain and we know
that he's not as enamored of some of
America's alliances as his predecessors
the u.s. maintains twenty 4915 active
duty troops in South Korea in the event
of a war the u.s. is committed by treaty
to send up to 690 thousand additional US
forces to reinforce South Korea along
with 160 naval vessels and 2,000
military aircraft South Korea has the
largest standing ready military of any
of America's 60 allies but even that
army is half the size of North Korea's
conventional forces the Heritage
Foundation's James Califano says it is
cheaper to keep US troops in South Korea
than bring them home Japan and South
Korea bear much of the sustainment costs
of facilities in Northeast Asia so
American taxpayer doesn't pay for all
this stuff the White House announced the
location of the summit today the
Cappella Hotel on sentosa island in
Singapore a five-star resort the meeting
will begin at 9:00 a.m.
even that took days to negotiate Brett
Jennifer Griffin live at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you